[Music]
Hollywood's biggest night is just around
the corner and et's here to help you
throw a viewing party fit for your
favorite ælis stars awards season is the
perfect excuse to get your friends
together and host a glitzy glammy bash
and I'm going to make sure you wow them
starting with the invites guys how cute
are these download these customizable
invitations all you have to do is add
your own address and time to the
template then print it on white
cardstock and send it out to all your
nearest and dearest okay so every party
has to have a dress code but I like to
keep it cozy so I'm thinking ask your
guests to come in black and white
pajamas but tap into that old Hollywood
glam by encouraging them to rock their
faux pearls faux diamonds bow ties and
top hats stick to black white and gold
for the decor and if you want to add a
pop of color just do it with your
flowers put them out on the food table
in a gold base and that'll be perfect
then if you want to add some real drama
just get some black balloons of
different shapes and sizes that'll
really make an impact on your space and
it's so affordable
preceding print up head shots of the
celeb nominees with their name on it and
then tape them to the chairs with washi
tape this could not be easier and it's
just like what the real show does when
they're planning out the seating chart
for the big event as your guests arrived
play a mix of classic movie scores or
songs from this year's Best Picture
nominees Alexa play my party mix give
those classic movie snacks a makeover
starting with a DIY popcorn station this
is so easy just take these cute little
containers they're black-and-white
stripes they're on theme and they're
tiny and everybody loves a cute little
food moment right I've put out a ton of
seasonings honestly anything that sounds
good to you will work but I have crushed
red pepper
I have cinnamon sugar taco seasoning
paprika truffle salt Parmesan the world
is your oyster go wild popcorn and candy
are no muss no fuss not to mention
totally delish and totally on theme and
while you're setting up keep yourself
entertained by playing one of your
favorite flicks Alexa play a star is
born
it wouldn't be a celebration without a
little bubbly and this is the
celebration of all celebrations in
Hollywood so bust out the champagne and
go ahead garnished with a black and
white stripe straw a teeny tiny black
balloon and how festive and how cute is
that document the night with your
friends by setting up a photobooth wall
nothing is as easy and as fun as that
just put up some black and gold metallic
fringe Garland and then set some props
on a table I chose to put out things
like most likely to make out with a
seat-filler and I'd like to think then
just put a sign on the table that says
lights camera action and pose it up keep
your guests entertained with a game I'm
gonna suggest you play Who am I you guys
definitely know this game from when you
were kids it's so fun we just put a
little twist on it and now it's an award
season theme download our template cut
out the cards that have the name of a
celeb
then place one card in each tiny
envelope create your own ribbon to give
it that awards envelope feel pass out
the envelope to each guest and have them
tape the celeb card to their forehead
without peeking the guest must go around
the room asking questions to other
guests to try and figure out which
celebrity name is on the card they are
wearing the first person to guess which
celebrity they are wins the prize and
keep it on theme hand out these cute
little prizes movie theater gift cards
everyone goes home with a swag bag so
when the show wraps up and it's time for
your guests to hit the road make sure
they don't leave empty-handed now that
is a totally easy but totally award
worthy soiree but I want to see your
party tag me in all your picks I'm at
Halle underscore Stephens and use the
hashtag how to throw
[Music]
[Applause]